[Musik]
Guten Morgen zusammen, ich hoffe, alle
sind noch süß frisch. Ich sagte nur zu
Yogi, es wird schneien, dann hätte er
all die unterschiedlichen Wetterbedingungen gehabt, die
wir möglicherweise
möglicherweise in drei Tagen gehabt haben. Es ist mir eine Freude
, unseren ersten zu begrüßen  Sprecherin heute Maya
Schechter ist Professorin für Philosophie an der
University of Illinois in Chicago, sie
hat in Harvard promoviert, und zu ihren
Forschungsinteressen gehört die
Autonomie der persönlichen Identität von Personen in der Bioethik, und ich
glaube, Girag hat eine ihrer
Monographien auf den Büchertisch gelegt
dort 2014 und hatte Oxford University
Press am Leben zu erhalten persönliche Identität
praktische Bedenken und die Einheit einer
Person Buch, das ich zumindest sehr
genossen habe, mein Gehirn zu lesen, um
Sie zu haben, und wir freuen uns auf
ein Telefon, also vielen Dank, ich auf
jeden Fall  Ich möchte diese Gelegenheit nutzen
, um Ihnen und allen
Organisatoren, den Kaffeelieferanten und den
anderen Rednern zu danken und mein Web-Publikum willkommen zu heißen
und ich danke Ihnen allen, dass Sie
morgens ehrlich sind, also habe ich Dias, weil
ich mit der Zeit voll
bin, obwohl ich in diesem speziellen Fall nicht sicher bin, ob
sie mehr tun, als Ihnen ab und zu ein Bild zum
Ansehen zu geben, also meistens ich  Ich werde
versuchen, meine Inhalte durch Ihre zu vermitteln,
aber wir werden sehen, tut
mir leid, tut mir leid,
also, wie ich Ihnen sagte, wird es nur
begrenzte Inhalte geben, also beginne ich mit
Nathaniel Hot Summer in der Kurzgeschichte
Wakefield, die er hat  schrieb und seine
Kurzgeschichten sind wirklich wunderbar. Ich empfehle
sie, wenn Sie sie sich noch nicht angesehen haben.
Der Erzähler denkt über eine Geschichte nach, die
er in einer Zeitung oder
Zeitschrift gehört hat, von der ihm gesagt wurde, dass sie wahr ist, wenn es
um einen Mann geht, den er Wakefield nennt
und Wakefield verließ eines Tages sein Zuhause und
kehrte 20 Jahre lang nicht zurück, und wie
sich am Ende der Geschichte aus
irgendeinem perversen Grund herausstellt, der nie
erklärt, was er auf faule Weise umgebracht
hat, wusste er nicht, dass er das alles gelebt
hat  Zeit gleich herum  Die Ecke von
seinem Haus, nur um seinen Haushalt zu beobachten
, den er verließ, und dann, nachdem
mehr als zwei Jahrzehnte gesagt wurde, sein
Nachlass sei erledigt, sein Name aus dem
Gedächtnis gestrichen und seine Frau sich vor langer, langer Zeit
mit ihrer herbstlichen Witwenschaft abgefunden hatte,
trat er durch die Tür, als er sich leise lehnte
wie von Tagen der Abwesenheit und so
grübelt der Erzähler darüber nach,
wie es für Wakefield wäre, nach diesen
20 Jahren zurückzukehren, und als er zu dem Schluss kommt, dass
Wakefield den Faden seines Lebens oder überhaupt nicht wieder aufnehmen kann,
sagt er, bleiben Sie Wakefield, würden Sie  geh
zur Seele nach Hause, das heißt
- dann steig in dein Grab und er
erklärt, dass inmitten der scheinbaren
Verwirrung unserer mysteriösen Welt Individuen
so schön an ein System und
Systeme aneinander zu einem Ganzen angepasst sind, dass man
durch einen kurzen Schritt zur Seite ein Mensch wird
setzt sich dem furchtbaren Risiko aus
, seinen Platz für immer zu verlieren,
so dass Wakefield am Ende als
eine Art Geist dargestellt wird, der nichts weiter kann, als
sein früheres Leben zu verfolgen, das er nicht verlassen kann  zurück
zu ihr, die so auf dem malerischen Gebiet gerührt ist,
weil ich denke, dass es einen so schönen
Ausdruck der Idee bietet, dass der Raum, den wir
im System einnehmen, aus sozialen
Interaktionssystemen besteht, die selbst
miteinander interagieren und mit natürlichen
Systemen zentral sind für das, was wir sind
Individuen und die
hier beschriebenen Verflechtungssysteme geben meiner Meinung nach eine schöne
Annäherung an das Phänomen, das
ich persönlichen Raum genannt habe und über das ich heute sprechen werde,
und das ist ein zentrales
Konzept dieser Sichtweise, das ich eine
Person wie Sie und die nicht nenne  Die Idee, dass wir das
Gefühl haben, seine Existenz irgendwie zu untergraben
oder zu bedrohen, indem wir
aus diesem System heraustreten, ist sehr kongenial
zu meinem Vorschlag, dass wir als menschliche Personen bestehen bleiben, indem wir,
wie ich es beschreibe
, einen Weg durch den Raum der Person verfolgen,
etwas, das ich offensichtlich
erklären muss und das  wir hören auf zu existieren, wenn
dieser Weg durch den Personenraum
zu Ende geht, daher möchte ich gleich zu Beginn anmerken
, dass die Hawthorne-Geschichte in keiner Weise impliziert, dass Wakefield l  Es hört wirklich auf
zu existieren, wenn Humor dieses
Experiment macht, das er offensichtlich die
ganze Zeit gleich um die Ecke in
diesem Ort gelebt hat, den er richtig gemietet hat, und ich
sollte auch gleich sagen, dass meine Ansicht
die Implikation hat, dass in dieser
Geschichte Wakefields Existenz buchstäblich endet,
wenn er  sich von seiner Hausschuld
befreit und ich werde später erklären warum, aber ich
lese das Ende dieser Geschichte genau so
sehr überdreht und gehe ins Grab, wenn
du zum Seelenort gehen willst,
dass dir das nicht nur als
Poesie zur Verfügung steht  Art zu sagen, dass
Wingfield etwas Wichtiges und Kostbares verloren hat,
indem er diese Beziehungen
abbrach und aus seinem Leben ausstieg, aber er sagt,
dass dieser Verlust in einem wörtlicheren
Sinne ist, um einen Begriff Fracht zu
verwenden, der in einem anderen Kontext in einem
ungewohnten Sinne wörtlich verwendet wird
Oh, wirklich ein Angriff auf seine bloße
Existenz, und ob dies eine
korrekte Lesart von Hawthorne ist oder nicht
, das möchte ich sagen und
ich möchte versuchen, es zu erklären
Ich möchte heute mehr schreiben, in welchem Sinne ich denke, dass
er Platz, den wir in einem System mensc
licher Interaktion einnehmen, das mit der n
türlichen Umwelt interagiert, ein Schl
sselteil dessen ist, was uns Integrität als einze
ne fortdauernde Individuen verleiht, und wie das V
rsagen, einen solchen einzunehmen  Ein Ort kann
diese Integrität auf eine wirklich
einfache und direkte Weise bedrohen, so dass die
Behauptung nicht nur darauf abzielt, was
wir in der Länge einer menschlichen
Person zur Verfügung haben, sondern auch darum, was ein
solches Leben tatsächlich ausmachen würde und was meiner Meinung
nach wiederum ausmacht  eine menschliche Person,
und so erweitert die Ansicht, die ich fordere,
kann als Ablehnung der Behauptung angesehen werden
, die in dem Zitat aufgestellt wird,
das gewissermaßen im Mittelpunkt stand, als wir
gestern als Kernstück der
Konferenz die Behauptung sahen, zu der Neural kommt
unsere Identität hat
entgegengesetzt, was die Übereinstimmung dessen,
was in unserer Identität wichtig ist, mit
den tatsächlichen Bedingungen unserer Identität garantiert,
obwohl ich wahrscheinlich nicht
Zufall oder w verwende  Was ist wichtig oder
vielleicht sogar so, denken Sie
so, wie es in diesem Zitat gemeint war,
aber ich denke, dem
möchte ich in gewisser
Weise widersprechen, also möchte ich ein klareres
Verständnis vermitteln als in dem, was  Daraus folgt,
inwiefern unser eigener persönlicher
Raum zu unserer Integrität als Individuen beiträgt,
sind all diese persönlichen
Interaktionsräume und wie
sich das auf konkurrierende Ansichten über die
Persistenzbedingungen menschlicher Personen bezieht,
insbesondere auf Animalismus, und ich dachte, das
läutet eine Beschreibung der beiden ein
Arten von hybriden Ansichten war sehr hilfreich,
und ich habe darüber nachgedacht, ob ich
das einzige X oder mein Prinzip ablehne oder
ob ich wirklich sagen möchte,
dass wir, wenn wir dieses Prinzip anwenden wollen,
sorgfältig darauf achten müssen,
wie sozial  Veränderungen und äußere
Veränderungen können den inneren Charakter
des Y auf eine Weise verändern, die wir normalerweise nicht tun, oder
die Art und Weise, wie sie miteinander verbunden sind, also
werde ich mit einem vorläufigen
Entwurf beginnen  der personalisierten Ansicht
besondere Aufmerksamkeit auf den Begriff des
persönlichen Raums richten, sobald dieser auf dem Tisch liegt
, scheint es, als würde ich
zuerst einen möglichen Einwand betrachten. Die
erste sehr schematische Präsentation, die
den Einwand beantwortet, wird hoffentlich die
Ansicht ein wenig verdeutlichen  ein bisschen und ich werde
hier nicht alle Details angeben können,
dann denke ich, dass es so aussehen wird,
sobald ich den Einwand beantwortet habe, dass es
so aussehen wird, als wäre dies wirklich eine Form
von Animalismus, das werde ich behaupten  es
ist nicht oder zumindest erklären, warum ich denke, dass
es nicht so ist, aber ich sollte gleich zu Beginn sagen,
auch wenn ich hier nicht unterscheide
, dass ich nur eine animalische Woche bin und
Mensch-Tier ist, aber es ist ein starker
Animalismus
, der ich bin  Die Vorstellung abzulehnen, dass
psychologische Merkmale keine Rolle in
unseren Persistenzbedingungen spielen, ist also in Ordnung, also
nach der personenähnlichen Sichtweise sind Wesen
wie wir grundsätzlich menschliche Personen,
es kann auch andere Arten geben, das ist
eine andere Geschichte, über die ich sprechen kann
na ein Mensch ist ein Wesen,
das eine charakteristische Art von Leben hinterlässt,
dem ich folge. Personenleben und menschliche
Personen werden durch
Individualisierung personalisiert. Eine menschliche Person
setzt sich fort, solange das einzelne Personenleben
dies natürlich tut und das Leben aus dieser
Sicht ein andauerndes ist  Prozess, der
Interaktionen zwischen biologischen,
psychologischen und sozialen Merkmalen beinhaltet, also
denke ich, dass ich auf diese Weise wieder eine
hybride Sichtweise gebe. Ich denke, das ist richtig,
obwohl ich anstelle einer Pest auf beiden
Häusern gerne sage, dass
Sie alle im wahren amerikanischen Geist sind  Willkommen hier,
also denke ich nicht wirklich über eine
Beschreibung nach, was jedes dieser Dinge
bedeutet, aber lassen Sie mich versuchen, durchzugehen und
ein wenig darüber zu sagen, was jedes
dieser Dinge
bedeutet  Um etwas Kontext bereitzustellen, lassen Sie mich zunächst
anmerken, dass die wenigen darauf abzielen, einige
der überzeugenden Aspekte sowohl traditioneller
psychologischer Darstellungen der persönlichen
Identität als auch eines Tieres
auf eine Weise zu erfassen, die sa wird  Beides, und
daher die hybride Natur davon wie der
Kapitalismus, lässt die Ansicht zu, dass die
biologische Kontinuität eine zentrale
Rolle bei der Persistenz individueller
menschlicher Personen wie uns spielt, und glaubt
, dass dies besagt, dass wir alle sicherlich einmal menschliche
Säuglinge waren, die wir konnten
Persistenz in einem vegetativen Zustand, aber das
Bild war weniger akut, so dass es früher
Säuglinge waren, aber wenn
diese traditionellen psychologischen Ansichten aus psychologischer Sicht betrachtet werden,
leugnet es, dass jeder von uns streng
identisch mit einem menschlichen tierischen Organismus ist,
und hält auch fest, dass unsere
Persistenzbedingungen inhärent damit verbunden sind
Praktische Bedenken, die schwieriger zu
finden sind, sind die Geschäftsleute von CW, die
praktisch sind, und Ellison,
daher ist es wichtig zu beachten, dass sich diese Ansicht
meiner Meinung nach sowohl von fast Formen
des Animismus als auch von dem psychologischen
Ansatz in der Konzeption der Person unterscheidet, die
sie verwendet, also sage ich hier in meinem  stellt fest,
dass sowohl der Animalismus als auch traditionelle
psychologische Kontinuitätstheorien
grundsätzlich ein L voraussetzen  Okean
Vorstellung davon, was es bedeutet, eine
Person zu sein Erik erinnert mich daran, dass Analysten
keine bestimmte
Vorstellung von Persönlichkeit voraussetzen müssen, also ist es vielleicht
falsch zu sagen, dass sie von einem
Glück ausgehen, aber die Diskussion sagt normalerweise, dass
wir der Person Persönlichkeit zugestehen
Lockean 70 verriegelt,
also sind gemäß dieser Vorstellung von
Persönlichkeit die Personen grob
gesprochen Wesen, wie wir immer wieder gehört haben
, die hoch entwickelte
kognitive Fähigkeiten wie Vernunft und Reflexion,
praktische Fähigkeiten wie moralische Entscheidungsfreiheit
und umsichtige Besorgnis besitzen, also sind wir die eigentliche
Meinungsverschiedenheit zwischen  Die Animalisten und
der Lockeaner sind bezüglich des ontologischen
Status, Menschen mit
psychologischen Theorien zu verbinden, zumindest implizierend,
wenn nicht immer sagend, dass dies eine
grundlegende Art von Einheit ist, die größer verbunden ist,
natürlich sagen sie es, aber viele
der Ansichten implizieren es, ich kann es perfektionieren  und
ich behaupte, dass ein Analytiker die Persönlichkeit als Gesichtskreis betrachtet
, während meine Ansicht für
eine inhärente Verbindung zwischen
Personh spricht  Die Verbindung zwischen guten und praktischen Merkmalen
ist auch
etwas anders als in den
traditionellen Lockeschen Ansichten. Es ist nicht so
direkt, dass die praktischen Merkmale
unsere Identität bestimmen, sondern so direkt
und auch die Bandbreite relevanter
praktischer Merkmale, die
Personen charakterisieren  Diese Ansicht ist viel breiter
und grundlegender als in der Lockeschen
Konzeption, und das ist wirklich eine
wichtige Einheit für mich. Das ist nicht die
Art von Person, die Sie kennen, worüber ich spreche,
also in Bezug auf die Verbindung mit einer
Person wie Ihnen  Ich verstehe nicht,
was Personen von Nicht-Personen in
erster Linie in Bezug auf bestimmte
Fähigkeiten unterscheidet, die
einzelne Personen besitzen, und das ist etwas
, was Thomas wusste, Schatz, ich meine, ich
denke, es stimmt sehr gut mit dem überein,
wovon er sagte, dass Personen eher
abstammen  die Art von Leben, die
Menschen charakteristischerweise verlassen, und
dies sind Leben, die von einer
besonderen Form komplexer sozialer
Interaktion bestimmt werden, also ist es das nicht  Meine individuelle
Vernunft und Reflexion,
die mich zu einer Person machen, ist mein Leben auf eine
Art und Weise, die durch komplexe
Formen sozialer Organisation vermittelt wird,
genauer gesagt, Personen, wie ich sie
verstehe, leben ein Leben, das durch
kulturelle Institutionen und Praktiken vermittelt wird, also
wenn Sie danach suchen  Sehen Sie, was
zwischen Menschen, die Sie kennen,
Menschen und anderen Tierarten
, die keine Menschen sind, anders ist. Ich
arbeite nicht an den spezifischen
individuellen Fähigkeiten, sondern an der Tatsache,
dass wir enkulturiert sind, was natürlich
damit zusammenhängt, dass wir
typischerweise haben diese Fähigkeiten auf alle
möglichen Arten, aber als ein anderer Ort
der andere Ausgangspunkt, so denke ich,
dass diese ich behaupte, dass diese
institutionalisierten, vorkontroversen
kulturellen Praktiken
die vielfältigen Arten von Interaktionen zwischen
Individuen, die in ihnen leben, bedingen und vermitteln,
einschließlich der  Arten von forensischen
Beziehungen dieses Blocks sprachen
über das Einhalten von Versprechen und
Attributen  Neben unserer Fähigkeit und unserem logischen
Denken gibt es auch viele andere
Arten von Interaktionen und hier bin ich
Paul Snowden dankbar dafür, dass er
darüber gesprochen hat, wie viel von unseren Lebensemotionen
und unseren persönlichen Emotionen und Einstellungen in
Bezug auf das, was wir miteinander tun, richtig ist
Es geht nicht ausschließlich um Vernunft und
es geht auch nicht ausschließlich um
forensische Interaktionen, richtig, also gibt es
fürsorgliche Beziehungen zwischen Eltern und
Kindern, einschließlich Dinge wie
Guckuck spielen und Lieder singen und solche
Dinge tun, das ist eine Kultur, die wir
vermitteln, eine zwischenmenschliche Interaktion, die
romantisch ist  beziehungen zusammen sport treiben
zusammen musik machen zusammen tanzen
gleich zusammen zu einer konferenz
gehen und dann essen
gehen vielleicht einen film sehen eine tourtour im
bus machen all diese dinge sind dinge
, die menschen tun und alle werden
dadurch vermittelt  kulturelle Institutionen
und soziale Institutionen und Praktiken, also
möchte ich in diesem Sinne sagen,
dass das praktische Element  s, die meiner
Meinung nach inhärent mit Persönlichkeit
und persönlicher Identität verbunden sind, sind viel umfassender
und grundlegender als die Lockeschen Freunde
und Fähigkeiten, die Teil des
Ganzen sind, aber was ich sagen möchte, ist
inhärent mit den
Bedingungen unserer Beharrlichkeit verbunden, ist so viel umfassender
Bereich praktischer Interaktionen und
Assoziationen, so dass diese Arten von
Interaktionen, viele der Arten von
Interaktionen, die Teil unserer
kulturellen Praxis sind, entscheidend von
unserer Fähigkeit abhängen,
Einzelpersonen im Laufe der Zeit zu verfolgen, aber sie stellen
auch die Verfolgung von Einzelpersonen im
Laufe der Zeit dar, möchte ich sagen, unsere  Array ist eine
sehr identifizierende andere Menschen sind in
die soziokulturelle
Infrastruktur eingeschrieben, sowohl implizit durch
viele Praktiken als auch explizit durch
soziale Institutionen und Lehren. Wir haben
Namensschilder. Ich war die Person auf dem
Zeitplan, dass wir kommen und diesen
Vortrag halten, weil ich es bin  angeblich
verbunden mit diesem buch als ich ins
flugzeug stieg bekam ich einen sitzplatz den ich meinem p zeigen musste
Assport schreibt überall, wir
haben diese Möglichkeiten, Menschen zu verfolgen,
die in der Kultur institutionalisiert sind, und
ich möchte sagen, dass dies einen Teil dessen ausmacht,
was einzelne
Personen am Laufen hält und vereint, also die Reihe von Codes
und Praktiken, über die wir
sprechen  Aber ich habe darüber gesprochen, ich sage,
definiert einen Raum zwischenmenschlicher
Interaktionen oder persönlichen Raum. Ich
habe diesen Begriff irgendwie beschrieben, und jetzt muss ich
sagen, was es bedeutet,
sisse, aber es gibt eine Art Web-Netzwerkraum
, der aus zwischenmenschlichen
Interaktionen besteht  durch die wir Menschen verfolgen
können, und deshalb möchte ich sagen, dass dem Sein
einer Person zugesprochen werden muss
und einen Platz im Raum zwischenmenschlicher Interaktionen einnimmt,
und eine einzelne fortlaufende Person
wird einen einzigen kontinuierlichen Weg
durch sie verfolgen, den BRE insgesamt identifiziert hat  Von
diesen Wegen, über die ich gesprochen habe, als einen
nachvollziehbaren fortwährenden Ort der zwischenmenschlichen
Interaktion, genau wie die Art, über die ich
gesprochen habe, geht es um dieses wirklich Denta
Fiying und Tracking, das mit dem zusammenhängt  Die praktischen
Belange durch diese Praktiken und
sie folgen einem erkennbaren
Weg. Es ist nicht so, als gäbe es eine
Vorlage dafür, wie man ein Leben führt. Es
gibt offensichtlich große Unterschiede in
Bezug auf einzelne Kulturen und Orte
in der Zeit, aber es stellt sich heraus, dass es
Arbeitsblätter für Lebenswege überall im Internet gibt
Also ich denke, es gibt diese Idee, dass wir
in der Lage sein sollten zu sehen, wie ein Single-
Lebensweg aussieht. Okay, also jetzt
, wo ich ein bisschen mehr über die
zentralen Ansprüche der Person gesagt habe, wie Sie
vielleicht erkennen, wenn Sie es nicht tun.  Ich weiß es noch nicht,
es wird sehr schwierig, aber ich
hoffe, es ein wenig zu ergänzen. Ich denke
, bei jedem von Ihnen könnte bereits eine Sorge aufkommen, es ist
sicherlich eine, die für mich aufgekommen ist, dass die
Ansicht in gewisser Weise sozialkonstruktivistisch sein könnte
Richtig, denn wenn ich
sage, dass unsere Verfolgung anderer
tatsächlich ihre Art der
Identifizierung darstellt oder eine Aufzeichnung an einem
Ort im persönlichen Raum sie tatsächlich
zu einer Person macht, scheint es
so, als könnte dies der Fall sein  sei moralisch besorgniserregend, richtig,
wir müssen nur entscheiden, wer eine Person ist, wenn
es sich um dieselbe Person handelt, richtig, ein Zwilling,
was es viele Gründe gibt zu befürchten, dass du
weißt, dass es physikalisch nicht plausibel ist, wie es
richtig läuft, das ist irgendwie nur X und y, wie ist
unsere Entscheidung oder Beurteilung  Jemand ist eine
Person, die Sie dazu bringen werden, dass
sie dieselbe Person sind, die
eine metaphysische Tatsache der numerischen
Identität darstellen wird, und wahrscheinlich beides, also lassen Sie mich versuchen
, eine schnelle Antwort auf diese Bedenken zu geben
, die helfen könnte, zu klären, was die Theorie dort
sagt  sind zwei Tatsachen über eine
Person wie Sie, von denen ich hoffe, dass sie, wenn sie
verstanden werden, dazu
beitragen werden, diese Sorgen etwas zu mildern. Die
erste ist,
dass soziale Faktoren zwar keine
Rolle bei der tatsächlichen Feststellung von Tatsachen der
Persönlichkeit und der persönlichen Identität spielen, dies jedoch nicht der
Fall ist.  Man kann nicht sagen, dass solche Faktoren die
einzige Determinante dafür sind, ob jemand eine
Person ist oder ob eine menschliche Person zu einem bestimmten
Zeitpunkt dieselbe menschliche Person ist
wie zu einem anderen Zeitpunkt  hält fest,
dass das Fortbestehen einer menschlichen Person
von biologischen, psychologischen
und sozialen Merkmalen abhängt, die nicht
nur mathematisch sind, wie Sie diese drei
Spuren haben und alle drei
haben müssen, der Punkt ist, dass sie eine
dynamische Interaktion miteinander sind  und
es ist diese Interaktion, von der ich denke, dass sie
übersehen wird, also denke ich, dass es auf diese
Weise Echos und
Berührungspunkte geben wird, die der Kaca
mit gutem Herzen spricht und
besonders ohne ein theistisches Gespräch über
die Art von Interaktionen, die für
Kreaturen wie uns existieren  Unter diesen verschiedenen
Dimensionen unserer Existenz ist es vielleicht
am einfachsten zu erklären, was ich damit meine,
wenn ich mir anschaue, inwiefern
die Behauptungen, die ich über menschliche
Personen aufstelle,
mit ähnlichen Behauptungen, über die gemacht werden kann, zusammenhängen und auch nicht
andere Lebewesen, also die Spitze von
Organismen im Kontext von Animalismus
gegenüber psychologischen Ansichten
, legt häufig, aber nicht offensichtlich, ein
Verständnis von Organismus nahe, in dem t  Die
Funktionsweise eines Organs, aber
die Funktionsweise eines Organismus zu verstehen,
bedeutet, zu untersuchen, was
biochemisch unter der Haut oder innerhalb
der Membran vor sich geht, je nachdem, um welche Art von
Organismus es sich handelt, diese Art
von innerer biochemischer Maschinerie, die sich
rekonstituiert und regeneriert und so
Aber in der Tat, wenn Sie
einen Organismus wirklich verstehen wollen
, müssen
wir zumindest seine Wechselwirkungen mit seiner Umwelt verstehen.
Solche Wechselwirkungen gelten als
absolut charakteristisch für Organismen
und sind absolut notwendig, damit sie
weiterhin ein inneres biochemisches
Funktionieren aufrechterhalten  Unversehrtheit eines
Lebewesens nur insofern, als die
Grenzfläche effektiv mit dem ist, was
außerhalb der Hautmembran oder was auch immer
es des Organismus ist, so dass für einige
Lebewesen der nächste Schritt besagt, dass die
relevante Art der Interaktion mit der
Umwelt unter anderem Interaktionen sein werden
mit einem sozialen Umfeld
und so ist dies ziemlich gerade  htforward
für Sie soziale Kreaturen wie Bienen da
oben und es gilt auf andere Weise für
viele Tiere, wenn sie in Herden
Schutz suchen, wo sie in Rudeln jagen, haben
Sie Ihre Wölfe dort oben, wenn sie
bei der Aufzucht von Jungen zusammenarbeiten, wie
ich glaube, Elefanten und so weiter  Richtig,
wenn diese Verhaltensweisen von entscheidender Bedeutung sind, wie die
Aufrechterhaltung der Funktionen des Organismus,
die ihre Integrität als Individuen aufrechterhalten,
genauso wichtig und
zentral, wenn auch etwas anders als
die inneren biochemischen Funktionen und
die Maschinerie, die Zellen repariert
usw., also das ist der zweite
Teil des  Planet und dann ist der nächste Schritt für
mich die Behauptung, dass für Wesen wie uns
Menschen im Vergleich zu unserem sozialen Funktionieren
Inkulturationsrecht besteht, dass
wir eine besondere Art von sozialem
Funktionieren haben, die andere Tiere, soweit
wir wissen, nicht kennen, also die genauen
Ursprünge davon  Kultur und Geschichte der Menschheit sind
offensichtlich nicht genau bekannt, aber was er
weiß, ist, dass es eine Rückkopplungsschleife gibt, sobald Kultur
auftaucht  Zwischen kultureller
und biologischer Evolution, so dass
Enkulturation eine Rolle spielt,
um hier aufrechterhalten zu werden
und so zu funktionieren,
wie es diese anderen Verhaltensweisen anderer
Tiere tun, und Sie wissen also, dass der
nächste Schritt ist, dass Sie Eltern-Kind-
Interaktionen haben  Sie werden in allen
vielen Säugetieren richtig sehen, aber hier gibt es
Brillen und sie spielen eine
bestimmte Menge an Akkulturationsmedikamenten,
und wenn Sie zu
Dingen kommen, wie dem Arzt, der Ihnen
Medikamente gibt, um Ihr Immunsystem zu stärken, haben Sie
Recht.  Wir haben eine viel klarere Kultur,
die an der Integrität der
individuellen Art von Dingen arbeitet, die richtig vor sich gehen,
also möchte ich sagen, dass
Enkulturation dazu kommt, unsere kulturellen
Interaktionen und Praktiken zu spielen, um
diese Art von integrativer
Rolle zu spielen, nicht nur diese  Verhaltensweisen
für einen Prominenten in unserem Leben wichtig werden
und dass sie die Art von Wesen charakterisieren, die
wir sind, möchte ich sagen, dass sie
mit unserem Biolog verwoben sind
Funktionieren auf sehr grundlegende Weise,
ähnlich wie Sie das Laufen in Herden kennen oder
wie Sie sich
für andere Arten von Tieren einsetzen können, und so
gibt es alle möglichen Arten, in denen diese
kulturellen Praktiken und biologischen
Funktionen miteinander verwoben sind, so
zum Beispiel über Generationen hinweg  die Entwicklung
der Landwirtschaft, Hygiene und Medizin
verändern Elemente der inneren biologischen
Funktion und die Bohnen, die sie
in einem individuellen Leben haben, die Existenz
von allem, von Musik über Sprache,
Impfungen bis hin zu Ernährungspraktiken, haben
alle möglichen direkten Auswirkungen auf die
biochemische Funktion des
Individuums.  werden die synaptische
Beschneidung des Babys beeinflussen sie werden Dinge beeinflussen
wie Statur Alter der ersten
Menstruation Wechseljahre Anfälligkeit
für alle Arten von chronischen Krankheiten wie
Diabetes Depression sie beeinflussen die
Lebenserwartung und vieles mehr, also sind dies
nur einige Beispiele für den Weg hinein  die
unsere kulturellen Praktiken ziemlich regelmäßig
mit unserem Bi interagieren  Die chemische
Funktionsweise und natürlich geht es auch in die
andere Richtung, genau wie wir
funktionieren, bestimmt, was unsere Praktiken
sind. Wir haben all diese kulturellen Praktiken
rund um das Fressen, die Paarung und die Aufzucht von
Jungen, denn das ist es, was wir Tiere tun
, das ist die Art von Ort, an dem Ihre
kulturellen Praktiken stattfinden  beginnen
richtig, wenn wir so weit leben, dass
Religion Sorgen über die
Sterblichkeit und die Schwäche des Körpers anspricht,
richtig, dass unsere Biologie eine Rolle spielt und
was dort passiert, also beinhaltet die Behauptung,
dass als Person gesehen, einen
kontinuierlichen Weg durch den Raum der Person zu verfolgen
Damit ist nicht impliziert, dass soziokulturelle
Praktiken ihre eigenen individuellen menschlichen
Personen oder ihren Durchgang durch
den Personenraum definieren, sondern dass unsere
Urteile und Praktiken auf
wirklich komplizierte Weise mit biologischen
und umweltbedingten Tatsachen interagieren und dass diese
miteinander verbundenen Funktionen
uns zusammen ausmachen  einzelne Entitäten
mit laufender Integrität, die über die Zeit nachverfolgt werden
können an  Ich mag das Thema, das
ich versuchen werde, weiter zu hämmern, ist nur, dass ich
mich frage, ob das nur die Idee ist. Natürlich
verursachen diese Dinge biologische Wirkungen,
es gibt Ursachen, aber es ist das, was
als Ergebnis davon passiert, und das macht
Sie gleich  Person Ich möchte sagen, dass die ganze
Dynamik auf und mit
Wollfuß zu erklären versucht, was das bedeutet, also ist mein
zweiter damit zusammenhängender Punkt, dass es Einschränkungen gibt, die
die soziokulturellen
Praktiken des
menschlichen Raums darstellen, die die natürliche
Geschichte des Menschen bevorzugen  sich in einem
natürlichen Kontext entwickelt und muss
sowohl auf Umweltbedingungen als auch auf
die biologische Natur von Personen reagieren und diese beeinflussen. Die
Praktiken der Interaktionsverdinglichung
, die sich entwickeln, können nicht willkürlich sein, wenn
die Kultur, die sie einschließt, nicht
nachhaltig sein wird  Die Folge dieser
Einschränkung, die ich hier nur
irgendwie zu schnell andeuten kann, ist, dass in
menschlichen Kulturen alle Menschen
automatisch als
Ich-Personen gesehen und behandelt werden  gemeine Tiere sehen ihre Art
von Besonderheiten auf eine bestimmte Weise und wir
sind unter anderem ein Malik-
Analytiker menschliche Tiere, also mag dies
nachweislich falsch erscheinen, wenn Sie sich die
Geschichte ansehen oder hassen, dass wir keinen
Mangel an Beispielen für Orte zu haben scheinen, an denen
Menschen  von anderen Menschen als
weniger oder keine Personen behandelt wurden, und das
wäre offensichtlich wahr, wenn das Konzept der
Persönlichkeit, das ich verwendete, ein erhabenes oder
kontinuierliches wäre. Wir sehen oder behandeln
etwas als Person, was bedeutet,
es gut oder mit Respekt zu behandeln  Aber ich,
weil Kultur offensichtlich verwandt ist, ist es
eher die Ausnahme, dass
sie institutionalisierte Praktiken haben
, einige Menschen im Vergleich
zu anderen sehr schlecht zu behandeln. Einige Menschen können schlecht
behandelt werden, sie haben nicht die gleichen Rechte
und den moralischen Status wie andere, aber da
Ich plädiere für eine grundlegendere Konzeption von
Personsein in dem Sinne, dass ich
Person meine, ich denke, wir müssen automatisch sehen
und erkennen und behandeln, um eine
nachhaltige Kultur zu sein  Menschen als
Personen in diesem grundlegenden Sinne,
weil es einfach eine Tatsache ist, dass Menschen
irgendwann charakteristische
kognitive und physische Fähigkeiten entwickeln werden und eine
Kultur, die nicht anerkennt, dass andere
Menschen ihrer Art sind, in diesem
Satz nicht sehr lange bestehen konnte,
richtig, so Sie  Sehen Sie dies in den
ungeheuerlichsten Formen der Misshandlung von
Menschen durch unsere Menschen. Wenn also Menschen
andere Menschen
erniedrigen, indem sie sie zum Beispiel dazu bringen, etwas zu beschmutzen, das sie für
heilig halten, oder
vor anderen, die richtig gekleidet sind, nackt zu erscheinen,
erkennen sie ihre  grundlegende
Persönlichkeit, weil nur bestimmte
Arten von Wesen auf diese besondere Weise gequält werden können,
richtige
Wesen, die in der Lage sind, Dinge
heilig zu halten, wie wir es tun, oder sich um ihre Nacktheit kümmern,
also Wesen, die fähig sind und
asiatische Kultur und ähnliches haben, wenn
Sklavenhalter Gesetze dagegen erlassen  Sklaven, die
Anti-Sklaverei-Literatur besitzen oder denen
das Lesen beigebracht wurde oder die sich in Gruppen versammeln,
sind ihnen irgendwie ähnlich  Eine Reihe von
Praktiken, die anerkennt, dass diese Sklaven
diese bestimmten grundlegenden
personenspezifischen Fähigkeiten besitzen, so wie die
Praktiken der Zuschreibung von Persönlichkeit, möchte
ich sagen, dass die Praktiken der Verfolgung und
Wiederidentifizierung von Personen, die
in soziokulturelle Institutionen eingeschrieben sind, nicht
willkürlich sein können oder ich  Menschen nicht nach
Vornamen verfolgen und es so ausarbeiten zu lassen,
wie Sie es möchten, wird es nicht zu
den identischen viktorianischen Zwecken passen, für
die Trapping stattfindet, also in
der Welt, in der wir leben, bedeutet dies, dass die
Fortsetzung einer einzigen  Person wird im Laufe der
Zeit mit dem
biologischen Leben eines Menschen zusammenfallen, sonst würden unsere
Praktiken der erneuten
Verdichtung nicht die Arbeit leisten, die wir von ihnen
erwarten, zum Beispiel erwarten, dass ein alter Freund
Sie erkennt, wenn Sie ihn sehen, oder dass Ihr
Arbeitgeber Sie bezahlt  für Ihre Arbeit oder das
Kind, das Sie impfen,
um eine gewisse Einheit gegen das Masernrecht zu haben,
müssen wir sowie auf
andere Weise jetzt neu definieren
Nachdem ich versucht habe, diese
Frage zum Thema Konventionalismus zu beantworten,
mag es seltsam erscheinen, dass ich diese Ansicht in irgendeiner Weise
als Konkurrent
zu Tieren beschrieben habe, wenn ich
letztendlich sagen werde, dass alle Menschen menschliche
Personen sind und dass dies der Fall ist  Die Dauer einer
einzelnen menschlichen Person im Laufe der Zeit wird
mit der eines einzelnen
biologischen Menschenrechts zusammenfallen. Was fügt die
Person hier hinzu,
warum heißt das nicht nur, dass jeder von
uns streng identisch mit einer menschlichen Person
ist, deren biologische Beständigkeit jeder von uns hat
?  Bedingungen im menschlichen
Tier jeder von uns hat die biologischen
Persistenzbedingungen kein solches Tier
und dann füge ich nur nebenbei hinzu
, dass es für diese bestimmte Tierart charakteristisch ist
, diese bestimmte
Art von sozialer Organisation zu haben, andere
Tiere haben andere, was wir  Alle
teilen zwar die richtigen biologischen
Persistenzbedingungen, aber ich meine,
das ist etwas, worüber ich mir Sorgen mache.
Warum sollten Sie sich darüber Sorgen machen, aber es ist
die Sache, die ich in Frage stelle  ist, dass Sie nur
Tiere sind, ich meine, ich denke, die Antwort ist nicht
und es ist die Sache, die
ich vorher haben werde, also ist die unmittelbarste
Antwort auf diese Frage, dass ich
denke, wenn ich das, was ich gesagt habe, so aussehen lässt, wir sind
menschliche Tiere und
Übrigens gilt das für Menschentiere, aber wenn diese
Art und Weise die Behauptung nicht ernst genug nimmt
, dass soziale Funktionen
regelmäßig
chemisch ständig mit biologischen
interagieren, um die Integrität des
individuellen Rechts aufrechtzuerhalten, das war es, was ich
versuchte  mit der Diskussion über
die allgemeinere Art und Weise zurechtkommen, in der die soziale
Organisation ständig
zum Fortbestehen
und Aufbau vieler Lebewesen beiträgt, aber
selbst wenn wir anerkennen, dass es
diese Rückkopplungsschleife gibt, oder vielleicht besonders,
wenn wir das Richtige tun, könnten wir immer noch fragen,
ob  oder das, was ich beschrieben habe, ist nicht
immer noch eine Variante von Tieren, warum
biete ich nicht einfach eine Version von Animismus an
, die sich von anderen Formen unterscheidet, indem sie
eine etwas breitere oder andere Form hat?  ferente
Vorstellung vom biologischen Leben und ich
denke, das ist Teil eins über Sofia Dinge
wie Schau, du kannst Animalismus rechtfertigen, wenn
du nur eine breitere Sicht auf Biologie
hast und das explizit machst, also warum tue ich
das nicht und hier ist, wo ich denke, wo
ich hingehen werde  unterscheiden, obwohl ich denke, dass dies
ein Weg ist, den Sie gehen könnten. Ich möchte sagen, dass
dies auf jeden Fall keine
Form von starkem Animalismus sein wird, und ich
werde abweichen, weil ich denke, dass ich nicht nur
soziale und psychologische
Aspekte vermitteln möchte  Ich habe nicht
so viel über die psychologische Tatsache gesprochen, aber beide
Arten von Faktoren spielen eine direkte Rolle bei der
Individuation und den Persistenzbedingungen
von
Personen  Im Prinzip
komme ich hier zu der hybriden Ansicht, dass ich es im
Prinzip nicht überleben könnte, in
einen anderen Körper verlegt zu werden, einen anderen menschlichen Körper, der
durch eine Großhirntransplantation oder ähnliches
gleich vorhin in unserer
Welt gesagt wurde  Die Dauer einer menschlichen Person
wird mit der eines menschlichen
Tieres oder Organismus zusammenfallen, aber in unserer Welt war eine
Verfälschung erforderlich, und deshalb
werde ich jetzt versuchen
, schnell zu erklären, wie ich denke, dass dies
möglich ist
und was es bedeutet, so oh  und ich habe diesen,
ich liebe diesen Kern von Peter Singer, ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher, in welchem Kontext er ihn verwendet, aber
s kommt so schön auf das zu, worauf es hi
r hinaus will. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir s
zial waren, bevor wir Menschen wurden, aber wir waren
COBOL  sozial Nun
, wir sind sozialer geworden, aber wir kultivieren es
gleichzeitig, also lassen Sie mich versuchen,
die Art und Weise zu erklären, in der ich denke, dass dies
wirklich keine Form von Animalismus ist, indem ich sage,
was meiner Meinung nach der wirkliche Unterschied ist  Dies ist ein
tiefer Unterschied in den metaphysischen
Annahmen über die Natur von Wesen
wie uns und vielleicht allen Wesen, die ich nicht
kenne, die hinter der menschenähnlichen
Sichtweise und dem Animalismus stehen, daher bin ich
Eric während seiner gesamten Arbeit besonders dankbar, dass
er so klar und deutlich dargelegt hat  ganz die
Art und Weise, in der mich spezifisch  tapphysischen
Annahmen, die die Argumente
für den Animalismus der Art und Weise, in der
Tiere und von ihnen abhängig sind, funktionieren, und ich
denke, dass sowohl analytische als auch traditionelle
psychologische Ansätze das voraussetzen, was
ich hier charakterisieren würde, kommen wir an einen Punkt
, an dem ich denke, dass
ich mit dem Prozess sympathisiere  Metaphysik, aber
ich verstehe es nicht gut genug, weißt du
sicher, aber beide Ansätze neigen dazu, das
vorauszusetzen, was ich nicht
nur als Dingmetaphysik bezeichnen würde, sondern der
wichtigere Punkt ist eine essentialistische
Metaphysik, das heißt, dass
es Individuen gibt, die gegeben sind  Für uns haben
diese Individuen Eigenschaften, und
diese sind wesentlich, und einige dieser
Eigenschaften sind für sie wesentlich. Es gibt
grundlegende Art-Substanz-Konzepte in
dem Sinne, dass sie Eigenschaften oder
Eigenschaften sind, die das Individuum nicht
verlieren und weiterbestehen kann, richtig, das ist
sehr klar  aber animalische Augen
, die ein Tier sind, höre ich auf zu existieren,
aber ich denke auch, dass es in der einzigen psychologischen impliziert ist
Alle Kontinuitätstheorien und
es ist sehr explizit und Linn-Baker Right,
die Art von essentialistischer Metaphysik, und
dann gibt es im Animalismus diese
weitere Annahme, und
wir haben gestern darüber gesprochen, dass der Organismus,
wenn überhaupt, eine grundlegende Art von
Organismus ist  Es ist ziemlich unwiderstehlich, ein Analytiker
zu sein, und ich habe das Gefühl,
wenn Sie sowohl an die essentialistische Metaphysik glauben,
wie ich sie beschrieben habe, als auch daran, dass der
Organismus eine grundlegende Art ist
, ein
Analytiker zu sein, ist es schwer vorstellbar, wie Sie
irgendetwas sein könnten  sonst richtig, weil Sie wissen,
dann tun Sie Dinge wie das Problem der zu
vielen Denker, die meiner Meinung nach wirklich
ein Problem sind. Es gibt offensichtlich diese sehr
seltsamen Ergebnisse, also meine ich offensichtlich, als
Baker brillante Arbeit geleistet hat, um dem zu
widerstehen, aber ich finde, Sie sehen alle
sehr gut aus  Stark, was ich in einer Person
wie Ihnen mache, ist, denke ich, einen anderen
Ansatz zu wählen und nur ein anderes
metaphysisches Modell anzunehmen, diese Ansicht stützt sich auf eine
Cl  Uster-Modell, nach dem menschliche
Personen von Natur aus
biopsychosoziale Dinge sind, wobei Nerd eine
dieser Facetten notwendig und vielleicht
keine ausreichend ist, ist eine
kompliziertere Geschichte für die Integrität oder
Beharrlichkeit der menschlichen Person und der
beste Weg, um zu verstehen, was ich meine
Dies geschieht durch eine Analogie mit einer
ähnlichen Sichtweise, die
mich in Bezug auf den biologischen Tod sehr beeinflusst hat
, die von Winston Chiang angeboten wurde,
und China tritt in den Streit zwischen
denen ein, die ein Kreislauf- und
Atmungskriterium für den Tod verteidigen, und denen
, die ein Ganzhirnkriterium unterstützen
Was er sagt, ist gut, anstatt zu versuchen
zu bestimmen, welches davon das
richtige Kriterium für die Rückkehr zum
Hybridmodell ist, sollten wir uns stattdessen
Leben und Tod als Clusterkonzepte
vorstellen, so dass es in seinen Worten
die Eigenschaft des Lebendigen wie
Eigentum ist  Eine Sprache oder ein Spiel zu sein, das
kleine Prise da unten beinhaltet eine
Anhäufung von Merkmalen, von denen keines das
ist  selbst notwendig und ausreichend, damit
ein Organismus am Leben ist, aber alle
tragen dazu bei, dass ein Organismus lebt,
und neigen dazu, sich in den Paradigmenfällen gegenseitig zu verstärken
ist sehr ansprechend, weil eine
standardmäßige und plausible allgemeine
Definition des Todes für Organismen so
etwas wie die unumkehrbare
Einstellung der Funktion des Organismus
als integriertes Gesamtrecht ist, und die
Biologie legt nahe, dass es
viele verschiedene Möglichkeiten gibt, wie Organismen
entweder fortfahren können  Als Zuhause fungieren oder
nicht mehr als Mauern fungieren,
zumindest in einer Welt, in der
Eingriffe und Interventionen möglich sind,
so dass im paradigmatischen Fall organisches Leben
das Funktionsrecht
aller wichtigen Systeme beinhaltet, also haben wir für ein Wesen wie
uns das Gleichgültige
das Kreislaufsystem läuft
und unser gesamtes neurologisches System
läuft, wir haben das Organ  Es ist etwas
weg, aber es gibt eine Menge
Redundanz, die in den menschlichen Organismus eingebaut ist,
und es gibt viele, die
jetzt zum Menschen zurückkehren, und es gibt eine Menge
künstlicher Eingriffe,
Lebenserhaltungssysteme, Medikamente, Dialyse, künstliches
Insulin, Antibiotika, antivirale Mittel und
all dies kann tun  Einige der Arbeiten, die
natürliche Systeme nicht mehr
ausführen können, und angesichts der Redundanz
können Sie auch ohne diese einige
Funktionen verlieren und ziemlich lange weitermachen,
also sind wir dort, wo
künstliche Kompositionen genau so der
traditionelle Ansatz zum Verständnis des
Todes sind  wird uns in Versuchung führen
, das Leben in Bezug auf die letzte Funktion zu definieren, wissen Sie,
was Leben ausmacht und was den
Tod
ausmacht
ist hier vielleicht nur
chronologisch richtig und das letzte,
was heruntergefahren werden kann, kann in
verschiedenen Todesfällen unterschiedlich sein und sozusagen
beginnen, y zu verlieren  unsere Funktion und allmählich
in vielen Fällen und abhängig von der Art der
Krankheit und ihrem Verlauf
kann es eine Vielzahl von Funktionen geben. Das
Aufhören könnte die
Integrität der Funktion des Organismus als
Ganzes untergraben, und so habe ich dieses komplizierte Web-
Ding auf die Beine gestellt  dort, weil ich meine,
ich denke, das ist das Bild, das Sie an so
etwas wie ein Netz denken, dessen Integrität
von all diesen miteinander verwobenen
Strängen abhängt, wenn Sie anfangen, Stränge
hochzuziehen, wird seine Integrität beeinträchtigt
und schließlich wird es auseinanderfallen, aber
Sie könnten es tun  es in verschiedenen Reihenfolgen
und was das letzte ist, was das
Ganze auseinanderfallen lässt, kann sehr unterschiedlich sein,
je nachdem, wo Sie
anfangen, wie es läuft und was Cheong meiner
Meinung nach sagt, und so ist das
menschliche organische System  Richtig,
Sie werden die Integrität des Funktionierens untergraben,
und schließlich fällt das Ding
so schnell auseinander, weil die
Zeit tickt. Ich möchte etwas
Ähnliches über menschliche Personen sagen und  Die
verschiedenen biologischen, psychologischen und
sozialen Funktionen arbeiten dann in paradigmatischen
Fällen zusammen, um ihre
Form und Funktionsweise aufrechtzuerhalten. Einzelne Fälle
werden sich sicherlich manchmal dramatisch von paradigmatischen Fällen unterscheiden,
so richtig, dass diese Menschen
unterschiedliche Funktionsweisen haben, verschiedene
Krankheiten usw. und die Frage ist,
inwieweit  sie sich unterscheiden können und auf welche Weise,
ohne dass die Integrität des
Individuums verloren geht und die individuelle menschliche
Person aufhört zu existieren, ist eine
komplizierte Frage, die je nach Kontext variiert,
aber es ist seltener zu sagen, dass der
Versuch, zu entscheiden, welche von
biologischen psychologischen und sozialen
Kontinuität ist die Form der Kontinuität
, die nicht verloren gehen kann, ohne dass die Person
aufhört zu existieren. Wir sollten anerkennen,
dass der Verlust jeder dieser Formen der
Kontinuität überlebensfähig sein könnte,
und beachten, dass der Verlust einer Reihe von
Funktionen mit ziemlicher Sicherheit Kosten verursachen wird
Effizienz und Probleme und die anderen,
also ist es sehr selten, dass es nur in ist
Philosophen denken, dann
würde ich eine Sache nehmen, und alles andere
funktioniert perfekt. Ich meine, oft reden,
wie es richtig ist. Schwere Alzheimer-Krankheit ist
etwas, das Sie biologisch nicht betrifft.
Es ist nur eine rein
psychische Beeinträchtigung
zu sagen, dass Menschen wie wir
in einem anhaltenden vegetativen Zustand überleben können,
aber es ist wichtig anzumerken, dass dies
meiner Meinung nach nicht einfach daran liegt, dass der
Organismus fortbesteht, sondern auch daran, dass
es alle möglichen praktischen Beziehungen gibt
, die fortbestehen, und so jemand, der
in einen vegetativen Zustand gerät  PBS setzt eine einzige Flugbahn
durch den persönlichen Raum fort. Ich meine
, das hängt stark vom Kontext ab, aber Sie
wissen, dass sie in unserer Welt in einem Krankenhaus sind
und eine Versicherung haben und die Leute
ihnen folgen, es gibt eine Menge
Fallen, in die sie verwickelt sind
zwischenmenschliche Interaktionen in irgendeiner robusten
oder sinnvollen Weise, aber es gibt sicherlich
eine soziale Kontinuität sowie eine
biologische Kontinuität  Allerdings hat
diese Ansicht auch zur Folge, dass eine
menschliche Person im Prinzip überleben könnte, wenn sie
durch eine Großhirntransplantation in einen anderen menschlichen Körper transplantiert wird, und ich
meine, wir müssen mit diesen Fällen vorsichtig sein,
weil sie zu Recht alle
möglichen Annahmen treffen, die falsch sind und wir
Ich weiß nicht, was ich meine, uns wurde oft gesagt, dass wir uns
wegen dieser fantastischen Fälle Sorgen machen sollen,
aber was ich bereit bin zu
sagen,
denken Sie an diese Fälle, ist eine Möglichkeit, sich
vorzustellen, wie eine soziale Praxis aussehen würde,
wie sich eine Kultur entwickelt, wie es unser Konzept ist
In diesem Fall ist es manchmal
wirklich schwer zu sagen, aber die
Transplantationsintuition ist so robust, dass Sie meiner Meinung nach
ziemlich sicher vorhersagen können,
dass, falls solche Dinge wirklich
möglich werden sollten, Sie sich genau genug vorstellen,
wo der andere Körper
sofort weg ist und so weiter
Sie  kann mir vorstellen, dass es
vollkommen natürlich wäre, eine Person in der Kultur zu verfolgen,
und die kulturelle Praxis
würde vorschreiben, sie mindestens zu einem neuen
Körper zu verfolgen  Tinte, das ist möglich,
und es werden vielleicht alle möglichen
Fragen dazu sein, und ich habe in den Fragen und Antworten
einiges darüber zu sagen,
und wo ich nichts zu sagen
habe, ist meine Strategie, ja zu sagen, also lassen Sie mich
schließen  Sehr schnell durch die Rückkehr
zum Anfangsmenschen sind einige von
Ihnen biopsychosoziale Wesen,
die den Verlust entweder der biologischen oder der
sozialen Kontinuität überleben könnten, aber was ist mit der sozialen
Funktionskontinuität, die zugegebenermaßen
hier eine besondere Rolle spielt, so dass die
Leute das oft annehmen, wenn
ich Ihnen das gebe  Ich sage, wenn du
auf eine einsame Insel gehen oder dich entscheiden
würdest, in den Wäldern zu leben, würde er
in gewisser Weise aufhören, eine Person von mir zu sein, sogar aufhören,
als Individuum zu existieren,
weil du keine Spur durch die Person hast
Raum, aber so funktioniert die Ansicht nicht,
ich meine, besonders wenn Sie einen Erwachsenen haben
und diese Person wie Tom
Hanks als Schiffbrüchigen kultivieren, da ist bereits so viel
Kontinuität eingebaut, und ich kann
das nicht mehr beschreiben, was ich nicht möchte  Denken Sie
zu viel mehr Zeit, richtig,
er ist schon dafür, es gibt viel
biologische Kontinuität, es
gibt viel psychologische
Kontinuität und es gibt viel
Enkulturation, das ist Wilson Wilson für
diejenigen von Ihnen, die diesen Film genau kennen,
da ist ein Fußball, den er zu
einem macht  Gesicht und interagiert mit ihm, weil er
so verzweifelt nach sozialer Interaktion sucht,
was meiner Meinung nach ein wichtiger Teil
der Geschichte ist, ebenso wie die Tatsache, dass Menschen,
die für lange Zeit sozial isoliert sind,
biologischen und psychologischen Verfall erleiden,
tatsächlich ist es nicht so
einfach, das einfach zu haben  alles andere
geht glücklich weiter, wenn Sie nicht die
soziale Interaktion haben, also denke ich, dass
ich alle möglichen Arten habe zu sagen, dass sogar
jemand wie dieser weitermachen würde, und
sicherlich würde Wakefield weitermachen,
weil ja, Wakefield sich
von seinem Haus fernhält, aber er zahlt immer noch Miete
er trägt immer noch Kleidung ist er isst immer noch
mit Besteck er macht immer noch
alle möglichen Dinge er ist sehr gefügig
und sein  Weil unsere kulturellen
Praktiken nicht so dumm
sind, haben sie die Möglichkeit eingebaut,
dass wir Fehler machen könnten,
und deshalb gibt es Gesetze für Dinge wie das,
was passiert, wenn Sie den
Nachlass von jemandem verkaufen und denken, dass er tot ist, und
Sie seine Frau zur Witwe erklären  aber dann
schreiben Sie eine biologisch und psychologisch
kontinuierliche Einzelsendung nach Hause,
20 Jahre später. Ich meine, wir haben Praktiken
zum Korrigieren von Fehlern, also ist die Ansicht
nicht einfach so, als hätten wir alle entschieden, dass
Wakefield tot ist, also ist er jetzt tot, das
wäre eine unplausible Ansicht, aber das
Die Ansicht ist eher, dass die sozialen und
psychologischen Komponenten so
mit der Biologie verflochten sind, dass es
wirklich künstlich ist, sie zu trennen, also denke ich,
dass der Fall Wakefield
jetzt nicht wirklich zu Ende geht,
um die grundlegende Bedeutung des persönlichen Raums zu veranschaulichen, den
er für alle überlebt  Die
Gründe habe ich gerade gegeben
und er tut es und einige Zellen kehren in
dieses alte Leben zurück, aber der Personenraum ist nicht
winzig, er besteht aus a  Ein großes Gewirr
zwischenmenschlicher Interaktionen wie dieses Netz, das
ich Ihnen richtig gezeigt habe, und nachdem er
Diskontinuitäten in einige der
grundlegendsten von ihnen eingeführt hat, hat er
einige Fäden in der Mitte von Wakefield herausgezogen und
das Netz, das sein Leben ist,
auf eine sehr grundlegende Weise geschwächt, genauso wie er es getan hat
Eine sehr schwere organische Krankheit
kann Ihre organischen Funktionen beeinträchtigen, selbst
während Sie biologisch am Leben
bleiben  Raum, der
andauert, er überlebt, aber er ist zerbrechlich
und empfindlich, und in gewisser Weise endet
er so sehr als Geist, als ob er
körperlos zurückkäme und keine Menschen anfassen oder
etwas essen könnte, richtig, wir haben viele
Geschichten darüber, sie sind irgendwie still
da, aber du bist nicht ganz da, also
möchte ich sagen, dass die soziale
Entfaltung eines Lebens in Wechselwirkung mit
seiner biologischen und psychologischen
Entfaltung Teil dessen ist, was Wingdin ist
uns als die individuellen Wesen, die wir sind, und
aus diesem Grund ist die Frage, ob
jemand Überstunden macht und unter
welchen Bedingungen empfindlich
auf Diskontinuitäten und Störungen entlang
all dieser Dimensionen reagiert, so dass wir es nicht so machen
, dass Sie dieses Individuum kennen  X
bei T 2 ist das gleiche wie Individuum Y bei T
1, nur weil es denkt oder sagt, dass es
der Fall ist, aber die Praktiken der
Interaktion mit der Anziehung anderer Tag
für Tag einen tiefgreifenden Einfluss darauf haben,
wie
die Entwicklung der Person auf allen
Ebenen funktioniert und damit ihre  Rolle dabei, uns zu dem zu machen
, was wir auf grundlegendste Weise sind,
sollte nicht übersehen werden, oder sie werden
geschätzt, dass in diesem persönlichen
Raum, in dem wir leben, vielen Dank